哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天又來到了我們的十分鐘心理學
這一次的十分鐘心理學
要跟大家分享的是什麼呢
那就是抱怨
抱怨這件事情喔
我曾經在我的粉專
有就是寫一篇文章
分享過我對這個事情的看法
很多人就會想說為什麼要抱怨呢
我也是一個很容易就是會抱怨的人
我那個抱怨就比較像是就東西寫不出來啊
事情做不完啊
然後呢書寫不出來
或者是之前課程一直弄不完等等
就會自己在沙發上滾來滾去說
啊我寫不出來了
我江郎才盡了
我完蛋了
就是這一種的
然後我在這個時候呢
抱怨這件事情其實對我來說充滿了力量
因為它會在我抱怨完這件事情之後
安撫了我的情緒
就是在我的正常能量釋放之後
我就會摸摸鼻子再繼續做
但是有些人就會發現喔
欸那聽起來這個抱怨還蠻正能量
可是有時候我們有一些抱怨
不見得有辦法那麼正能量
它可能會讓我們
一直重複的掉進同樣的循環裡面
並且不停地就是
發現自己都在抱怨一樣的事情
有些人就是會覺得
我身邊有人會這樣子一直抱怨一樣的事情
我覺得很煩
或者是說我自己覺得我會抱怨一樣的事情
為什麼我會這樣
我覺得這件事情
會回到一個非常重要的關鍵
那就是
其實抱怨這件事情，就是
有著怨氣嘛
所以我那個怨氣是什麼
代表我有一些事情
覺得自己不被公平地對待
覺得自己被虧待
或者是說不按照我的意願
我被權威要求不得不這麼做
所以我有怨氣
我有一些憤怒
我有一些不開心
我有一些不愉快
就別人可能侵犯了我的界線
但是我不能說
比如說是老闆叫我做的
雖然我不想這麼做
可是因為他是老闆
我不得不做
類似這種感覺
所以你可以感覺到抱怨這件事情
多半你有經驗到一些憤怒
然後一些委屈
當然委屈其實也跟憤怒有關
委屈就是 我憤怒、但不能表現出來
我有意見不能講出來
就變委屈嘛
所以抱怨其實有很多這個部分
因此抱怨這個部分，除了憤怒之外
它還有一個很重要的關鍵
那就是無力感
你在抱怨這件事情的時候
為什麼你需要抱怨呢
因為在面對這件事情的時候
你可能會有一些無力感
什麼叫無力感
例如說我被不公平對待了
我覺得很不甘心的無力感
例如我不得不按照他的方式去做
我覺得很不願意的無力感
因為我就是人在屋簷下
不得不低頭
然後或者是我感覺到
我在很多選擇裡面
我沒有辦法
我好像不得不這麼做的那個無力感
這一種抱怨
其實我們也常常在網路上看到
例如說有些人他就會寫
他經歷到一些什麼被不公平的對待
或是遇到一些店家
或是遇到一些合作對象怎麼樣
然後他就把很多東西很詳細的寫出去
與其說希望大家評評理
倒不如說我要讓你們看見
我是被不公平對待的
這個其實也是一種抱怨
那就是我沒有辦法跟當事人直接溝通
我只能用這樣的方式
去讓大家看到就是這件事情的呈現
當然有些人會說我已經溝通了沒有用
所以我才這樣說
沒錯所以那個無力感是很明顯的
就這件事情它沒有辦法只留在我們之間
它一定要讓我拿去跟第三者說這件事情
因為只有這樣
我才會感覺到我的那一些怨氣
在我們之間不管是不平等也好
或是無能為力也好
或是覺得憤怒也好
那些沒有辦法處理的情緒
藉由我跟第三者的訴說中
它有辦法獲得一個理解跟排解
這件事情很重要
所以呢
在我做抱怨這件事情
如果我能看清楚這個東西
我們就可以瞭解到一個狀況
所以這個抱怨它其實有幾個功能
什麼功能
第一個
它可以維持我現在 跟原本
我在抱怨的那個人的關係
就是我現在假設我在抱怨我的老闆
我在跟我的同事抱怨我的老闆
我抱怨完老闆之後對我的好處是什麼
好處就是我跟同事感情會變更好
有可能啊
就是大家同仇敵愾
然後就感覺
哦 互相被同理這樣子
第二個是
我好像也可以感覺
就是我對老闆的那些怨氣那些怒氣
好像有一個發洩的狀況
我就比較能跟你相處跟溝通
第三
還有一個部分
那就是
當我感覺到
我只能被你控制的那個無力感很痛苦
可是如果我跟同事一起抱怨你
說你怎麼那麼笨
你怎麼那麼蠢
就是這個老闆真的很北七
怎麼會這樣子想事情等等的時候
我其實可以藉由這些抱怨 得到掌控感
得到控制感
我是那個比較聰明
比較看得懂比較有力量的
我只不過是現在就是
人在屋簷下不得不低頭
只好跟著你做錯誤的選擇
但是我其實是那個比較聰明伶俐的人
我是那個比較有能力的人
它可以幫助我們得到一個有力量的感覺
所以我的無力感可以藉此解決
我的憤怒也可以因而發洩
因此它就可以幫助我做什麼事情
它就可以幫助我留在現在的狀況裡面
繼續的接受
不管是被老闆的不公平對待也好
或者是他要我做
我其實一點都不認同的事情等等
就可以讓我繼續的忍耐下去
所以抱怨很大的一個部分
就是讓我們安於現狀
那麼安於現狀這件事情到底算不算缺點
我覺得就是
平心而論
要看你的狀況
比如說你今天有經濟的壓力
你有家人要養你有很多很多壓力
今天要馬上動這件事情對你不是那麼容易
你需要儲備好彈藥、儲備好你的資源
做最好的選擇
其實一動不如一靜的時候
那或許抱怨在幫助你去做的事情
是讓你可以繼續留在現狀裡面
它某方面可以幫助你
就是健康的情緒釋放
而且如果你抱怨的時候你有意識的話
你就會發現
原來你很在意這些事情
原來你很在意老闆他要你做的事情
跟你的價值觀不符
原來你很討厭
有的時候主管請你做事情
他的態度不好
原來你很在乎
你的下屬他們在做事情的時候
想得不夠細或沒有禮貌
就是你會藉由這些抱怨
更清楚你腦中在意的那一些價值觀
跟眉眉角角是什麼
這其實都在幫助你
之後你要做新的選擇的時候
那些所有的規則
去幫助你去做你最好跟最想要的新的選擇
所以它不是一件完全不好的事
但我覺得最大的困難是
當我們今天在做抱怨的時候
如果我沒有意識到這件事情
我只是純粹的在發洩我的情緒
永遠都覺得我被虧待
然後永遠都覺得我在裡面無力改變
而那都是因為別人的位子比我高
然後我人在屋簷下不得不低頭
然後我也沒有別的選擇
那些憤怒跟無力感很容易讓我們憤世嫉俗
於是呢
我們就會聽到類似這樣子的狀況
甚至把自己視為受害者
不停的重複同樣的抱怨的狀況
反而是會讓我們或是讓旁邊聽的人
會讓人特別特別不舒服的
是因為這樣
好
講到這裡可能有些人說
老師所以就是像這樣的人
我們應該要糾正他改變他
不能讓他繼續當受害者
不過我反而會偏向一件事情
那就是受害者劇本
就是在我的內耗課裡
我有講到受害者劇本這件事
有買課的朋友
趕快去看一下複習一下
受害者劇本這件事情
它是一個非常常見的狀況
非常常見的就是
我沒有覺得它是一個很大的問題
為什麼
因為受害者劇本它跟幾件事情有關
我感覺自己是無力選擇跟無力改變的
第二 我感覺有別的更大的力量
可以控制我跟影響我
所以這在我們這麼受到權威教育
跟制度影響的臺灣社會裡面
我覺得這根本就是極為常見的東西
所以這不是個人的問題
這是歷史共業啊各位
所以我覺得如果你發現你有受害者劇本
千萬千萬不要覺得
天啊我怎麼會有受害者劇本
我真的好糟糕
其實不管是受害者劇本或是英雄劇本
英雄劇本就是我都要當拯救者
其實大家想解決的都是一樣的問題
那就是我在面對被人控制
跟被人影響的無力感的時候
我該怎麼做
是就被打趴然後順應
但是心裡很不爽
所以繼續抱怨
還是我要就是超越他
我要控制他我要影響他
但是我就變得每一件事情我都要這麼做
我要那麼用力
其實大家會有不同的生存策略
因此我覺得這是生存策略的問題
而沒有覺得哪一個是對或哪一個是錯
我覺得困難的應該是我們要去看
我們怎麼樣習慣性的這樣思考
然後讓我們掉進這樣子的選擇裡
我們的目標不是為了做對的選擇
我們的目標是為了讓自己更多選擇
各位永遠不要忘記這件事
我認為我的所有podcast
還有所有的十分鐘心理學
都不是為了要讓大家做正確的選擇
因為我認為沒有什麼事情是正確的
你在遇到某些人的時候
你當受害者其實比較輕鬆
我說真的
你當受害者
就天啊我就爛我做不到
像我出去玩的時候遇到我先生
我就是
你好棒喔我什麼都做不到
我什麼都做不好
然後他就會做很好
我就很輕鬆嘛
那就很開心嘛
也不一定要一定很糟糕
可是我的意思是當它變成
長期你看自己的一個狀況的時候
先不說別人感覺怎麼樣
你內心的那個無力感跟挫折感
會讓你很憂鬱
甚至自我傷害 自我懷疑
所以這才是問題
所以這才是問題...
因此我們的重點是要讓自己有選擇
而不是說哪一個選擇
一定要是最好或最棒的
這個先跟大家提醒
因此回到抱怨這件事情
如果今天我發現我很習慣掉進這種
就是覺得都別人壓迫我
我很可憐 我很悲傷的這個狀況
我需要去意識幾個事情
第一個
我每次抱怨到底想得到什麼
就我抱怨裡面有我的價值觀嘛
我有覺得什麼事情是好的
什麼事情是不好的
第二個就是
我最在意的是什麼
第三個
我有沒有想改變什麼
第四個
我有什麼資源可以讓我
做一點點新的選擇跟新的改變
我覺得所有的事情都有一些原因
我今天抱怨這件事情
我可能還覺得要改變這件事情
對我來說成本很高
所以我寧願用抱怨的
或者是我想要藉由用抱怨跟
覺得自己很可憐的方式
去跟人連結
欸有很多爸爸媽媽會用這樣的方式
因為我如果用可憐的方法
我的小孩會同情我
這很正常
很多時候是「鏡像神經元」在運作
我脆弱的時候 別人會來安慰我
這是我們很習慣的一種人際互動
因此有的時候我的抱怨
不見得是我覺得我多無力
而是因為我想要獲得一些愛跟照顧
所以你越清楚你為什麼要這麼做
那麼你就越知道
你做這些東西你想獲得什麼
在抱怨的狀況下
你就越有選擇
你現在要抱怨或是不抱怨
而這個抱怨它為你達到的目的是什麼
它就不會成為一個會困擾你的事情
但如果你覺得你身邊有人很喜歡抱怨
而你覺得很苦惱的話
我倒是蠻鼓勵你可以思考幾個問題
第一個
在這一個抱怨底下
你覺得對你來說最困擾的是什麼
其實有很多人就說
哦我身邊的人一直抱怨
我覺得很苦惱
我覺得很有趣
我每次聽到這個問題 都覺得很有趣
因為我想說這有兩個可能性嘛
第一個可能性就是
你一定得聽
沒有一定得聽啊
你如果不想聽的話
你可以用非常非常多的理由
離開現場跟不要再跟他見面
或是不要聽或是打斷他
其實你有非常非常多方法
可是你沒有這麼做
就有可能有第二個可能性
那就是你認為你應該聽
或者是他這個狀況
你覺得聽與不聽是另外一回事
你最受不了的
其實是他一直處在這種
就是無能為力
跟一直抱怨現狀的狀況下
是讓你最受不了
我覺得第二個東西才是最需要處理的
因為對我們而言
看到自己重要的人或是在乎的人
或是身邊的人
處在一個非常痛苦跟無能為力的狀況
對我們來說是很難忍受的
所以我們會想盡辦法
想要改變他的這個狀態
因為他的無力感會傳達到我身上
讓我也感覺到很無力
就是我們在內耗課有講到
如果你是比較偏高功能的人
你可能會覺得
喔 我就是好討厭這種無力感
所以我想盡辦法把自己變得高功能
結果這個人現在身上充滿了無力感
他要把他的無力感傳到我身上
我就會用我處理自己無力感的那一套
去處理他
但是他不是我
所以呢
他不會接受我那一套
我就會感覺到更無力
於是我就會對他的抱怨
非常非常的不爽不舒服跟生氣
我不爽的其實不只是他的抱怨本身
而是我對於這個狀況
我沒有辦法做些什麼改變他
讓整個狀況變好
也沒有辦法讓他的狀況變好
所以我們需要去理解的就是
我在乎的事情是什麼
如果我今天在乎的事
喔
如果他只是想要情感連結
那我就是給他一些回應
讓他知道我有在聽
那也很好
如果我想要讓他看見些什麼
我也可以告訴他說
我最近常常聽到你抱怨同樣的事情
我在想這件事情對你很重要吧
所以你覺得在這一個狀況下
你最想要我幫你什麼
或是你最想要我做什麼
只是想要我聽嗎
還是希望我給你一些支持
或是需要我給你一些方法嗎
你可以問問對方他希望你怎麼做
這也是一個做法
但是如果說你今天也沒想怎麼做
你就只是想要不聽
可是你沒有辦法做到這件事
那你要思考的就是界線這件事
也就是說
今天我沒有那麼想要擔任這個角色
就是抱怨的對象
我不想擔任這個對象
我卻又不想讓你知道的原因是什麼
是不是因為我認為我讓你知道
就會傷害我們彼此的關係
我們這個現狀可能會受到破壞
我就會需要時間去思考
我內心的這個擔心
它對我的影響
以及我到底需不需要讓對方
知道這件事情
這是選擇
所有的東西
所有的界線
建立與不建立
都要付出代價
這個代價
沒有好壞
沒有對錯
沒有怎麼做才是最好的
可是只有我們可不可以承擔這個代價
因此在這個部分跟大家分享
今天十分鐘心理學
抱怨對我們的影響
以及抱怨所代表的意義
還有我們面對抱怨
我們可能有什麼其他的選擇
跟大家分享
那麼十分鐘心理學就到這囉！
我們下次見～
掰掰